[MUSIC PLAYING]
DALE MARKOWITZ: Father's
Day is about a week away,
and like a lot of
people, I'm not
going to be able to
see my dad this year.
He's in New Jersey,
and I'm in Texas.
So I decided I would try
to build him something
that's easy to share digitally.
A machine learning-powered
searchable video archive.
And at the end of this
episode, I will share with him,
and we'll see what
he thinks of it.
[SPINNING REELS]
My dad has definitely always
been the primary video man.
My dad's first video was
the day that I was born.
So he has his camera
on me in the bassinet,
and I'm looking
very red and gooey.
And then my mom has
just given birth.
And it's amazing
that she allowed
herself to be on camera.
And since then, he's just been
taking tons and tons of video.
So a couple of years ago, my
dad uploaded all of our family
footage to Google Drive.
So I decided to build my dad
an AI-powered video archive,
which would allow us to actually
search through all the videos
and find the most
interesting bits.
Here's the searchable
video archive
that I ended up
building, that allows
you to search text and
transcripts and objects
by term.
Let's take a look
at how I built it.
The first step of
this project was
to transfer all of my dad's
videos from Google Drive
to cloud storage.
This way they'd be accessible
to the rest of my GCP project.
If you're using files
on your desktop,
you can just upload them
directly from within the UI.
But if you're transferring
files from Google Drive,
check out my blog to
see the hack I used
to make uploading much faster.
Next, I analyzed
all those videos
using the Video
Intelligence API,
which is the main AI workhorse
at the center of this project.
This tool takes
a video as input,
and it spits out lots of
different annotations,
like what's actually
going on in an image.
Is it a wedding?
Is it fireworks?
A cute dog?
[BARK]
It uses computer vision to
detect objects and events
in videos.
It also transcribes the
audio track from videos
so that we can later
search by what people say.
This is how I was able to
search for my very first steps.
DALE'S DAD: That's Dale walking.
This is the first
time she's taken
major steps on this floor.
DALE MARKOWITZ: It can also
grab text shown on screen,
so you can search for things
written on T-shirts or posters
or on signs.
Or on birthday cakes--
this is how I found
my first birthday.
I also used this feature
to grab the timestamps that
appeared on screen in some
of my dad's older videos.
Once I extracted all of
these searchable features,
I could use them to quickly
search through those videos.
Now, using the Video
Intelligence API
is pretty straightforward.
You just import the Video
Intelligence library
and call the Analyze
Video function,
passing a path to the location
of your stored video in cloud
storage.
Now, because my video
files were massive,
I tried to do all
of this processing
exclusively in the cloud,
because downloading things
onto my desktop would
have been really slow.
I chose an architecture
that looked like this.
First, like I
showed you earlier,
I uploaded my videos to a
cloud storage bucket, which
is like a folder in the cloud.
I used uploading a video to
trigger a Cloud Function.
In that cloud function, I called
the Video Intelligence API,
which analyzed
the uploaded video
and wrote the data to Firestore.
Finally, I needed a
way to quickly sort
through all of this data.
So for this, I used a
handy non-Google tool built
by a company called Algolia.
It's a search tool that
lets you upload JSON,
and then offers an API to
search through it quickly.
It handles things like
correcting for typos
and finding the most
relevant results.
So that was pretty much
how I built the back end.
To build a front end
or our user interface,
I decided to learn how to use
Flutter, which is a Google
framework for building apps.
And I built a Flutter web
app, which looks like this.
Of course, there
are tons of ways
you could build a front
end without Flutter, using
JavaScript or for IOS
or Android, your choice.
And that's it in a nutshell.
If you want to learn more
about the technical details
of this project or
to see the code,
make sure you check out my blog
post linked in the description
below.
All right.
I guess it's time to show
this app to a real user.
Let's show it to my dad.
So, Dad, I built something
for you for Father's Day,
and I'm really excited and also
really nervous to show you.
DALE'S DAD: Uh-oh.
DALE MARKOWITZ: It's probably
the most high-effort Father's
Day gift I've ever worked on.
DALE'S DAD: Oh,
look at all this.
I see Scooter and
Monticello, so I think
I know where this is going.
Oh, wow, look at all this.
Wow.
I know all these pictures.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So I took
all of your video in Drive,
and I analyzed it with machine
learning so that, first of all,
I split all of your
really long two-hour clips
into little chunks, and
I made them searchable.
So in addition to these ones,
Father's Day and Performance,
you can search by
anything that you want.
DALE'S DAD: That's interesting.
So can I search for, let's
say, we used to play ping pong.
You think the ping pong
table might show up?
DALE MARKOWITZ: Yeah, try it.
DALE'S DAD: Oh, look at that!
There it is.
I remember when I--
when we bought your first
bicycle, how excited you were.
So how about-- wait, this--
look it here.
This is what I was looking for.
This video right here.
But it brought all these
other bicycles in, as well.
How neat.
Every one of these pictures
has the bike in it.
But this is the specific
one that I was looking at.
So, yeah, I would have
definitely found it.
Very neat.
So you really could be very
loose with your search terms
here.
You know, I guess the looser
it is, the more likely
you are to find it, and
then you can just zoom in.
I guess you can get specific,
if there's a lot of occurrences.
This is very nice.
Thank you very much for the
early Father's Day gift.
I can't wait to show Mom.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Of course.
That's all I wanted to show you.
Thanks for filming with us.
DALE'S DAD: OK.
So how do you need
me to end this?
DALE MARKOWITZ: Oh, I have
an idea, I have an idea.
Can you search for Fade Out?
DALE'S DAD: Oh, yeah, I
said that all the time.
I think at the end of
every video we said that.
Let's see, if I--
let's see how long this one is.
OK, I'm going to
fade out, pussycat.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Can
I go on the bike?
DALE'S DAD: We're not.
DALE MARKOWITZ: We're not.
DALE'S DAD: You sure?
You sure we're not
going on the bike?